non vedevo l'ora di registrare questo
video ve lo giuro sono giorni che voglio
farlo finalmente oggi faceva roba
diversissima dal solito ve la spiego
perché è una bomba una bomba vera si
chiama al gioco dei video correlati il
cos'è allora voi sapete che quando ho
cercato video su youtube tipo anche
questo a destra di compaiono a destra vi
compaiono tutte le cagate qua sotto di
video correlati di altra gente che non
dovete cliccare the cliccare sui miei
però vabbè questo gioco l'ho visto fare
dagli eau topi una settimana fa
praticamente touche e gli due parole che
non c'entrano niente l'una con l'altra
non c'entrano assolutamente nulla e
tutta la prima parola di riuscire ad
arrivare alla seconda tramite i video
correlati come prima tentativo
cercheremo di arrivare da salvini ad
avengers endgame che non c'entrano
niente l'una con l'altra però devo
cercare di farlo tramite il video
correlati da savini ad avenger flat dop
[Musica]
termini che ripartiamo da salvini video
a caso di salvini pan
perfetto allora da salvini ad avengers
and games sarà un casino però proviamo e
ci troviamo qualche cosa con supereroi
super dove c'era il supereroe quindi
qualche cosa che nel titolo possa possa
avvicinarsi a un supereroe da salvini
non mi viene in mente proprio niente
però luciana littizzetto spaghetti cacio
e pepe forse con che tempo che fa
possiamo avvicinarci in qualche modo non
lo so lo ha trovato così ai centri qui
supereroe ragazze sicuramente non è
maria de filippi
mio dio los angeles
marcello sky ha intenzione los angeles
los angeles potrebbe avvicinarsi sta
cosa dai ragazzi daidalos da los angeles
ed i consiglieri dei film qualcosa
wonder prossimi versa studios universal
studios arriviamo nel mondo dei film
attenzione bellissimo se vuoi dirmi vuoi
dirmi che non c'è niente con universal
studios che si avvicina di supereroi
niente da gravemente a proviamo ancora
los angeles sempre di affidare baia chi
salvarmi culo o iron man iron man
da citare qualcuno gli ha chi ti amo
fatti limonare fatti limonata iron man
manca niente manca un niente forse col
versus potrebbe consigliarvi qualcosa
programma animals wengè visto
allontanando però non c'è niente di
supereroi quindi mi devo dopo staccarvi
da questa roba qua infatti adesso mi
butto solo gli animali porco demonio non
possono anche tornare indietro tra
l'altro tron tensione c'è tron che
potrebbe già avvicinarsi un po di più
perché si parla si parla sempre i film
ok allora tron è quello giusto
tron light bike attenzione attenzione
tron
allego urquell e google che siamo già
supereroi e leggo hulk quando spiderman
anche service
vabbè superpowers supermario capitan
america il captain america attenzione ma
aveva leggersi la datazione fermi
infinity ward infinity ward marvel
avengers infinity ward ragazzi marvel
avengers infinity ward ma anche io haven
jazz indie game
eccolo ce l'abbiamo bravo ryan bravo
bravo rai world 23,8 milioni di iscritti
moggiona guardi iscriviti annuncio sono
accendono l'accesso ma fa niente da
salvini ad avengers enti che la pensavo
molto più facile ragazzi vi dico la
verità non pensavo fosse così difficile
pensavo di cavarmela meglio con ragazzi
che non si deve vedere nel video la cosa
basta che nel titolo ci sia la parola
annessa tipo avengers anche in qua c'era
anche se è un video di un bambino basta
che ci sia scritto a reggio a sentire
quindi da savini ed avengers e l'abbiamo
fatto bene il secondo ragazzi e da
cristiano ronaldo ad happy wheels
[Musica]
e da cristiano ronaldo ci siamo allora
da ricchi se non altro non so dove posso
arrivare adempi wings la più pallida
idea saranno tutti i video di calcio
tutta la vita quindi devo allontanarmi
prima possibile
andiamo su juventus challenge ora da
juventus challenge passiamo a tutto
tutto calcio ovviamente qui questi sono
quiz dove ricercare tipo cosa come
crossbar challenge perché alla fine chi
è che portativo portò ai più rischi non
c'e nessun altro e quindi devo andare
più su fogli j quasi però per trovarlo
madonna dal calcio impossibile radio
veramente difficile michael spampinato
vorrei essere grosso quanto un tuo
muscolo tra l'altro prova veniamo anche
perché se riesco a mettere pizze mette
bis tecnis technip fort knight step di
attenzione attenzione se c'è sterni dai
proviamo step li vediamo da tanto ma
prima che si poteva spuntare io devo
sfruttare io quindi prima che studi io
ci metterò un botto dai raga la sterlina
fa vj dovrebbe essere un attimo
teoricamente poi vediamo
ok poi ct manutenzione ford nate qui tre
video che ho fatto
allora eccolo fantastico bravo sono
stato vivace dico che sono bravo da solo
perché è come sei stato questa la prima
avrei detto mica facile
diaries hard ai bts questa è veramente
idea di come fare
[Musica]
ma non vedo proprio il modo in cui io
possa passare da charlie sordi bts però
vabbè dai charlie dal contro plastica ma
allora pts
come faccio a beccarli non ne ho la più
pallida idea proprio però vabbè vediamo
se non avessi cantanti come faccio
andare su cantanti hanno spento aspetta
aspetta aspetta fammi gtv visto cosa
c'entro io a charitas shiny che lo trovi
in un video vero vero vero vero sezione
open si è fatto un sacco di visto video
anche la mia faccia merita vediamo se
riesco a trovare perché io ho fatto le
reaction anche hip hop quindi potrebbe
avere un senso stare su di me anche se
non vorrei farlo perché io ho fatto
veramente le 10 ma che però non prima di
arrivare a quello non va bene forse
troppo difficile peccato perché la
reaction echi pop potevano aiutarci ma
non so come portarci da ragazzi mi serve
la musica starpro grande re sulla star
numero uno al mondo sempre mi al video
però che non si parla di star gabry
ponte
gabry ponte potrebbe avere un senso
perché si trova nei musica musica musica
musica ci ho messo che aprì fonte metti
una canzone ma l'inizio ma una una
canzona sola non avete neanche uno
allora andiamo su italia's got talent
vogliamo sele scaricare qualcuno che
canta qualcuno che scavano tra lacuna
che canta con il beatbox va bene
bisboccia vene avena bene beatbox wings
con beatbox arabs got talent ok qui in
guns'n'roses c'è di tutto tranne il che
hip hop maledizione billy highline
abilitabili hai un black nikbakht nick
fermi fermi fermi fermi black pink
tensione non si sa come peccato prima
del black pink ci siamo siamo senza un
sud che hip hop
siamo sul keep hope bds tutto qua raga
tutto tutto qua tutto ciò database liu
chun l'algoritmo a youtube nel cervello
e ovviamente
questa allora questo forse ancora più
difficile dell'ultimo da greta thun berg
a quando i bambini fanno di povia ma
questo è impossibile
[Musica]
allora questo questo questo veramente
non so questo ovviamente non ho idea di
come arrivare ai quarti ma questo già
farò mai mai ce la farò mai
ce n'è anche se l'arrivo a sanremo ce la
faccio però proviamoci allora gretta
tuba in qua devo uscire mort fanpage
fanpage lorenzo baglioni baglioni
incredibile ha fatto tutto di me 19 non
ho ancora visto
questo proprio devo beccare baglioni è
andato a sanremo è quindi attenzione
potrebbe creare un sound sanremo che per
sanremo ma ragazzi impossibile il 2005
fare no questo è proprio difficili
ragazzi questo è veramente impossibile
impossibile il giro questo impossibile
se non becco sanremo ma neanche tra
vent'anni riesco sanremo saremo in 20 18
attenzione attenzione attenzione
[Musica]
attenzione attenzione sanremo rimaniamo
sulla scia sanremo è sanremo mettimi
altro caso di sanremo sanremo e
clicchiamo su enrico papi dai abbiamo
cliccato su enrico papi solo canzoni
scommettendo mettimi canzoni gabry ponte
va bene dove si rimandano sì come simona
nost i due va bene sanremo 18 dai dai
gabbani almeno rientro nel giro delle
canzoni o va bene va bene va bene cavani
max pezzali ok già siamo entrati nel
giro canzoni pianeti di ultimo va bene
almeno almeno mi mette come così a delle
canzoni sono porca che solo youtuber
lion non c'entra niente
fabrizio moro luca era gay
signori e signore signori signori
signori signori the quelli di povia
tutte tranne l'unica che l'unica famosa
tutte becco o è cristo però non trovo
questo video
[Musica]
proprio lui tutto qua tutto qua tutto
qua
allora fatemi sapere qui sotto visto che
questa la prima episodi voglio farne
tanti perché mi piace tantissimo giugno
fatemi sapere qui sotto nei commenti
quale se volete un altro episodio e
quali abbinamenti fare quindi fatemi
sapere qui sotto i commenti più votati
quindi commentati come tipi votati
saranno le scelte del mio prossimo
episodio di video correlati quindi
fatevi due cose non c'entra niente tipo
windows 98 e adolf hitler lo sparando
schiacciando il mi piace se vi è
piaciuto il finto lasciate un commento
di scritte dal canale e noi ci vediamo
come sempre al prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]